>>Jon Larimer: Hi, everyone.
My name is Jon Larimer, and I am a security
engineer on the Android team based out of
sunny Atlanta,.
>>Kenny Root: My name is Kenny Root.
I'm a software engineer on the Android team.
>>Jon Larimer: We're here today to talk to
you about security and privacy in the Android
Apps that you guys are developing and publishing.
And we're going to dig right in.
Let's talk about why you need to take security
into account when you're writing apps and
why it's important to protect your apps and
your users' data.
I'm sure you've all seen the headlines.
There's a major security breach here, a major
privacy leak there, some popular mobile app
gets caught collecting too much data.
The users are furious.
The blogosphere is freaking out.
The media demands answers.
And even the politicians are getting involved
to speak their mind.
So this is pretty serious stuff.
When stories like this hit the mainstream
news outlets and people talk about it in bars
and in taxi cabs, it shows that people really
are paying attention to the privacy practices
and security issues in mobile apps today.
And it would really ruin your day if you woke
up one morning and saw the headline that was
about your app that your company produced
that you actually spent time developing.
You don't really want the wake-up call from
your boss with PR and legal on the line, asking
what's going on and what you're planning on
doing to fix it.
And the problem isn't really that developers
are collecting personal user data.
Sometimes a fundamental feature of your app
requires it.
The problem is the lack of transparency.
And the problem is not notifying the users
of the data you're collecting and what it's
been used for.
And even if you aren't purposely collecting
personal data without telling users, your
app can still allow an accidental personal
data leak if you aren't taking security into
consideration.
If your app stores or transmits any personal
data insecurely, malware authors or hackers
could end up using this data without you or
your users knowing it.
And if your app is collecting too much data
or even if it has too access to too much data
through the permissions that it requests,
people start to worry.
And they have the right to worry, and they
really should be worrying.
So how many of you guys have seen negative
reviews on your apps because of the amount
of permissions that your app needs?
A few of you.
Probably a lot of you.
Some of you aren't raising your hands.
[ Laughter ]
>>Jon Larimer: I see a lot of these reviews
all the time.
So my point is that people are getting more
and more distrustful of apps that ask for
access to their personal data without any
clear reason for what you're planning on using
it for.
So our talk today is about how you can write
apps with privacy and security in mind.
And we'll talk about ways to protect your
app's data from malicious apps that are on
the device and how to prevent your app from
being a springboard from privilege elevation
attacks or information leaks.
And we'll tell you ways that you can minimize
the number of permissions that your app requests
and -- so you can lower the impact of a potential
attack.
And we'll talk about the tools and the documentation
that we have to help you write secure apps.
So people today, they use their phones for
everything now.
They surf the Web.
They read their email.
They take pictures, they get driving directions,
they interact with all of their friends through
their social networks.
And people can customize the way they do these
things by installing different apps.
But for these apps to work, they need to have
access to the data that basically defines
your life, your list of friends, your location
on the planet, where you're going and where
you've been, and who you're talking to.
So mobile devices are very powerful now, but
they're also a treasure trove of very private
personal data on the phone's owner and even
all of the phone owner's friends.
So Android just doesn't hand out this data
to anyone that wants it, as you undoubtedly
already know, being Android developers, the
Android permission system protects the data
and the capabilities on your phone.
So when a user installs an app that wants
to access this data or some capability of
the phone, the user gets to see the data and
the capabilities that you're wanting to access.
For example, if your app wants to send SMS
messages, the user can see that your app wants
to do this through the permission system.
And if somebody wants to download a game and
they see that it's requesting access to read
all of your contacts and send SMS messages,
a lot of times, they'll think twice about
downloading it.
So when you write an app that accesses the
data on a device or even produces data on
a device, for example, a social networking
app where a user enters their own content,
you need to take very good care of this data
and you need to be a good data custodian.
There are bad guys out there that would love
to abuse this data for purposes that the user
never really intended it for.
And, first of all, people generally don't
like giving out their personal information
to strangers, they really hate it.
You can go ask someone on the street for their
name and email address and phone number and
see if they'll give it to you.
And they probably won't.
You can ask him for a list of all of their
friends and their friends' phone numbers,
but they're not going to give this data.
But it seems like a lot of app developers
are expecting people to just hand over all
this information for no reason.
And besides the general discomfort involved
in giving out all this personal data, people
need to worry about the -- the folks that
write malicious software, the malware authors
who write apps that try to mine mobile devices
for data.
What do the bad guys want to do if they get
a piece of malware on a user's phone?
Well, the user's phone number and email address
could be harvested for sending unsolicited
advertisements, robo calls, and spam emails.
Their contacts could be collected, too, so
all of their friends start getting spam emails.
And the more unscrupulous or Black Hat marketers
and spammers will pay big bucks for collections
of detailed personal information on lots of
people.
But that's really not the only way to make
money from having access to a mobile device.
There are criminals out that there want to
take advantage of your user's phones to send
premium SMS messages that directly charge
your phone bill.
And then there are the real serious criminals
out there that would love to transfer money
directly out of your bank account, for example,
intercepting the two-factor authentication
messages that your bank sends over SMS.
So these are just a few of the reasons that
the data and capabilities on Android devices
really need to be protected.
But so what does this have to do with the
apps that you write and didn't I just get
done saying that Android protects all this
will data?
Well, even well intentioned apps that are
insecure could end up leaking data and other
device access to malicious apps.
And when a user installs your app and they
approve access to the permissions that you
request, they're trusting you with that data
and those device capabilities.
They have faith that you aren't going to leak
this data to bad apps and that their email
address won't start getting spam because of
your app and they're trusting that all of
their contacts won't be solicited unsolicited
SMS messages because of your app.
So the goal of this talk is really to make
sure that you don't let those users down.
So you really need to be aware that if your
app requests a permission, a security vulnerability
in the app can end up granting equivalent
access to another app that doesn't request
that permission.
So even if you aren't willfully violating
your user's privacy, a mistake in your code
could end up leading to some other bad actor
doing that kind of thing.
One example I have of this kind of security
vulnerability is, for example, storing the
latest GPS location in a world-readable file.
And I've seen this a few times, and maybe
your app does this.
Hopefully, it doesn't.
If it does, you should go fix it immediately
after this session.
So if you store the GPS location in a file
that any app can read.
This means that another app can access the
phone's location without requesting either
of the access location permissions, either
access course location or access find location.
You're basically removing the effectiveness
of the location permission that Android normally
requires to read the location data.
Another example would be exporting a content
provider that stores sensitive personal information.
So let's say that you are developing a note
taking app where the user can take notes and
save their notes, and you might implement
a content provider so the different components
of your app can all access these notes through
a uniform API.
And if this content provider is exported and
doesn't require any permissions, then that
means that any app on the phone could end
up reading the user's private notes.
And the user could be keeping, like, really
private, sensitive stuff in here and they
might not have any idea that you're making
it available to any other app that's on the
phone.
And you could think -- you could think that
you're being really smart and encrypting the
backing store for the file or encrypting the
database and thinking that the malware authors
or the hackers won't be able to access it.
But if you're providing an open API where
any app can read the data, then your encryption
is basically worthless, your users are still
at risk, and your app is really a security
headline waiting to happen.
And so another one that we see a lot is logging
personal information in the logcat logs.
We've seen people logging email addresses
or even passwords for the logcat logs.
And it's usually just leftover lines of code
from debugging that people forget to remove.
But it's a pretty serious problem.
And we have made some improvements to the
logging system in Jelly Bean to prevent this
kind of thing from being abused.
So apps in Jelly Bean can no longer read the
logcat logs for other apps, which is good.
But it's still a very bad idea to log any
personal data to logcat logs, regardless of
that.
Besides worrying about other malicious acts
interacting with your apps, you need to watch
what you do over the network, sending unencrypted
personal data over a wireless network is really
bad.
You should be using encryption whenever possible.
If you're transmitting data over an unencrypted
link, you might as well be broadcasting it
to the world.
Imagine your user is walking around with a
billboard floating over their head showing
all of their personal information and the
contents of their documents or even their
contacts' personal information.
Like I said, this is bad.
You need to encrypt anything that goes over
a wireless network.
And then there is also the issue of lost or
stolen phones.
And it's really up to the user to protect
access to their physical device.
But making your app more secure can still
help here.
Because you don't want to accidentally provide
a back door into someone's phone if they lose
control over it.
So that's what our talk is about today.
We're going to get into more detail about
these possible security holes and how to prevent
them.
If you pay attention to what we're saying,
hopefully, you won't have to worry about dealing
with the consequences of a major security
or privacy breach with your app.
So the first piece of advice I want to give
you is that you really need to let your users
know what you're doing with their data.
If your app is transmitting or collecting
any user data, meaning any data that you get
from the phone by requesting permission or
any data that the user manually enters into
the app, make sure that you have a privacy
policy.
We allow uploading of -- we allow uploading
privacy policies to the Play Store now so
that users can read it before downloading
the app.
So you don't have to implement your own sort
of UI for showing a privacy policy.
This helps you be more up-front and transparent.
And most users really appreciate this kind
of thing.
And the privacy policy should spell out exactly
what data you collect.
And I really mean exactly.
So if you're collecting email addresses and
names, say names and email addresses.
If you're collecting phone numbers, say phone
numbers.
Don't just provide a blanket policy that says
that you are going to collect whatever data
you want and do whatever you want with it,
because that's not useful and you might as
well not even have a privacy policy at that
point.
Something else that you want to do, it's a
pretty good idea to give users a choice.
If you want to collect all of their contacts
for some reason, ask them and let them know
why you want this information.
Let them know what benefit that you're providing
to them in exchange for this data.
And you should really give the users an option
to select which data they want to give you.
All or nothing isn't a great option.
So let them select a subset of the contacts
that they want to share with your app.
But, really, the most important thing that
you need to do is just be transparent about
what data your app collects and what you're
doing with it.
So something else that's really important
to keeping your app secure is keeping your
developer account itself secure.
The Play Store Developer Console lets you
upload apps and publish your apps and update
your apps.
So you really need to protect your account.
If someone else gets access to it, they can
publish apps as you, which if they publish
some really bad apps, it would make you look
pretty bad.
They could also get access to your financial
data.
They'll see how much money you make from selling
your apps and all of your in-app content.
So one of the best ways to prevent unauthorized
access is by using two-factor authentication.
You can download the Google authenticator
app from your phone and require a one-time
password when you log into your Google account.
And if you don't have two-factor authentication
enabled for your developer account, that's
another one of those things where after this
session, you should go enable it, because
it's really one of the most effective things
you can do to protect your account.
So another tip is, if you want to give another
employee or a partner access to your developer
account, don't give them your password.
We've seen this happen, and it really kind
of scares me when people do this kind of thing.
So we added the ability to grant access to
other accounts to your main developer account.
So you don't have to give out your password.
You can grant access by email address, and
you get to choose whether or not this person
can see the financial data.
So you can end up -- you can create a single
authoritative account for your company, and
then other accounts can be granted access.
And this way, a single rogue employee can't
take your account hostage.
If you're just granting access to other people,
you can revoke that access without changing
the master account password.
So if someone leaves the company on bad terms,
there's -- it kind of limits the damage that
they can do.
>>Kenny Root: Next we're going to talk about
the app signing key.
You might ask, what is an app signing key,
well, as Android developers, you've already
been using it.
You might not have noticed because in a normal
development work flow, in Eclipse, using the
ADT, or Android Developer Tools, your app
is signed automatically before it's installed
on the device.
And that's because any app installed on Android
device must be signed with a signature before
that's -- or must be signed with a private
key before it's allowed to be installed.
However, if you're distributing your app in
the -- whoops -- if you're distributing your
app in the Google Play or sending it via email
to someone else, you'll have to generate a
release key.
This is a unique key to your app.
And it provides -- any update you want to
provide for that app must be signed with the
same key.
Another cool property of this key is, if you
sign multiple apps of the same key, you can
use things such as shared user IDs between
the apps to look at each app's data, or you
can use a permission level of signature, which
we'll talk about later.
Because the signing key is part of the app's
identity, it can be used to update your app,
you really need to make sure that you protect
this signing key.
So a big company might have something like
a hardware security module or HSM where they
have little a ceremony where they sign the
app's keys.
I don't know, they might have put on special
hats.
As a home-brewed developer, you might just
have your key on a USB stick that you stick
in your fireproof safe.
But the most important part is you need to
keep a backup of this key.
But whatever you do, don't keep that backup
in your source repository or package it in
your app.
We've seen people do this before, and you're
basically giving your private key away to
the world.
Oh, and by the way, since you have to sign
with the same key to have updates, if you
lose that release key, you're not going to
be able to update your app.
You're going to have to tell users to uninstall
and install a new app with a different key.
And you can see by the Google Search results
that it happens quite a lot.
And we've even received support calls about
this.
And I'm sorry we can't factor your key to
find the private key again.
But, you know, I don't want to get a call
from you guys about losing your key, because
I don't want to tell you, sorry, that I can't
fix your key for you.
Now, that we know how to keep your accounts
and your key secure, let's talk more about
Android security itself and the features it
offers developers.
So the security architecture for Android has
several layers.
The first layer is that each application runs
in its own process space and as its own unique
user ID.
There are some exceptions such as being signed
by the same certificate allows you to run
as a shared user ID.
But, generally, you can imagine that each
application is separated by kind of a little
firewall between them.
It's a process space.
This -- the Linux kernel provides a separation
between the processes and different user IDs,
which forms the basis of the Android sandbox.
And this sandbox gives developers the flexibility
they need to make wonderful and innovative
apps without jumping through hoops to go through
different problems they might have.
And the sandbox also ensures that apps -- or
interactions between each app component are
protected by the appropriate permission check.
For instance, if your app was accessing the
file system, Linux kernel provides file system
security.
So what the Linux kernel would do is see what
your app's user ID is, what the file's owner
is, check the permissions.
And if that checks out, allow you to write
from or read to the file.
Or you can imagine as a developer you might
want to enable Wi-Fi peer-to-peer mode.
But you can't talk directly to the Wi-Fi peer-to-peer
or the Wi-Fi driver and the kernel, so you
make a call to the Wi-Fi manager API.
So in the backend, this actually uses a binder
IPC mechanism or interprocess communication
protocol or method to talk to the system server.
And the system server would then check your
app's permissions, what it was granted when
it was installed.
And if it's granted, it would talk to the
Wi-Fi kernel driver for you on your app's
behalf and enable Wi-Fi peer-to-peer mode
if you have that permission.
But it's not limited to calls to the system
server.
You can provide components to other applications
for them to interact with, and you can do
something like maybe you have a foreign language
word list for an input method editor.
Or you could have a match-making service for
a game to find other opponents.
You could provide a simple interface for a
complex communication protocol, like Secure
Shell, or you could have a calendar provider
that goes up to the cloud to grab your next
appointment.
You know, it's really limited to whatever
you can imagine.
Android is unique in that there's freedom
within your app's process to do what you need
to do.
This provides a lot of awesome possibilities.
But it's also different from a desktop VM.
And I have a kind of a story.
I was trying to write a tool for the Android
SDK.
I thought, you know, I'd just write it in
the Java language because it can run on Linux
and Windows and Mac OS.
But it turns out I ran into a problem.
I was trying to use the password-based key
derivation function number 2.
It's kind of a mouthful.
But it's PBKDF2.
It turns out, in Java, it's only available
in some operating systems.
I thought, oh, boy, I'll just use my own implementation
and provide that through the Java cryptography
architecture.
But it turns out in some G -- some VMs, you
can't install your own JCA provider and some
VMs you can.
So it's kind of a headache.
But in Android, you won't have that kind of
headache.
You can do what you need to do, and you'll
be much happier.
But it also means you have to be aware of
some things.
You can use reflection in your own application
to do what you need to do and it allows you
to do cool things like building dynamic code.
But it also means that protections for methods,
fields, and classes, like protected and private,
aren't absolute.
And you can do some really gnarly things in
your own code using reflection.
I wouldn't really encourage that, though,
I'd just stay away from it.
Or you can use JNI, which is a native interface
for applications, and it's allowed developers
to do some really, really cool things, like
port in the latest game engine or use a third-party
library to speed up development.
But it also means that in native code, you
can do anything in your own process space.
There's not really a restriction.
So you can also scribble on the Dalvik manage
(indiscernible), which can really cause some
bizarre behavior.
If you're processing things in native code,
like images or anything, you can inadvertently
cause a security exploit by allowing a buffer
overflow.
In the worst case, you'll provide the security
It might just have a segmentation fault.
It is a cause of really bizarre behavior.
>>Jon Larimer: So next we'll talk about what
it takes to actually write a secure app.
We'll talk about the potential problems you
might face and solutions for those problems,
we'll tell you the best practices that you
can employ to take advantage of the security
features that the Android platform framework
and operating system offers.
So here's a typical application.
It has a few activities.
There's a service running in the background.
The service talks -- the service has a settings
file that it reads and writes to, there's
a database with a content provider that provides
access to it.
The app is Internet-enabled and it talks to
the cloud.
So when you look at this diagram, can you
tell where the attack surface is, which of
these components could have a security vulnerability
or some kind of data leak that would leak
data or capabilities from Android?
And the answer is all of them.
Every single component here could be exposing
data if the developer -- if you guys aren't
taking the necessary precautions.
The activities could be leaking personal data
to the log file, the service could remote
calls from other apps that don't have permission,
the settings file could be world readable
or world writeable allowing access to the
service.
The content provider could be granting access
to the database and the database file itself
could have insecure file system permissions.
And even the data being transmitted over the
network could be in clear text or the web
service itself could be compromised.
Now, this isn't really as scary as it looks.
Android actually makes it pretty easy to prevent
most of these kind of attacks, except for
the cloud one there, we can't really protect
your web server.
But it's often easier to write a secure app
in Android than it is to write an insecure
app.
You just need to know what to do, you need
to know what's safe and what's not safe, and
once you really understand the risks and the
security model of Android mit starts to become
like second nature and we do have some tools
to help keep you on track.
So now Kenny will tell you about the different
types of application components and how to
protect other apps from accessing them if
you do not want other apps to access them.
>>Kenny Root: So each component provided by
your app is declared in the Android manifest.
And this is a way in which the system server
and specifically the activity manager and
package manager inside the system server knows
the entry points to your apps.
And these entry points can be services, activities,
broadcast receivers or content providers.
And each one of these components can have
intent filters associated with them which
tells the system server which intent data
you want these activities or services or whatever
being matched for.
An intent filter signals to the Android system
that you want these components exposed to
other apps.
And with without an intent filter, most components
are not available to other applications with
the exception of the content provider which
is exported by default.
So it's a good idea to get in the habit of
explicitly marking components as exported
or not.
This is not strictly necessary, but it will
help you prevent mistakes you make in the
future.
For instance, if you didn't intent a component
to be exported and maybe seven months later
you come back or a coworker comes in there
and adds an intent filter for something they
need, they might inadvertently export that
component and it could cause a security vulnerability
later.
If you do wish to make your -- whoops, wrong
slide.
If you do wish to make your components available
but only for limited use, there are permissions
you can grant in the Androidmanifest.XML.
These may be listed to the user upon installation,
depending on the protection level they're
at.
So if you have a protection level normal,
it's for permissions that you're granting
to an application that don't really expose
any user data, but you might want the user
to be aware of if you're scrolling through
the list of permissions that are in there.
Dangerous is for things that could expose
user data and you do want the user to be aware
of.
And finally there's a permission level of
signature which allows you to provide components
to other applications signed by the same app-signing
keys we discussed before.
So here's an example of how you define a permission
on an Android manifest.
Shows that protection level is restricted
to signature and that means the same app-signing
key that you sign this app with and it's protecting
our service example.
So if you didn't want the service example
available to other applications or exported,
it's a good idea to leave that signature in
there and just mark "exported false."
This is kind of a belt-and-suspenders approach
and it just ensures that if there's any problem
with the exporting in previous platform versions,
then it's not exported, if you have the same
sign-in signature.
So the Android manifest provides really coarse
permission-checking, basically all or nothing
for some things.
But if you need to check individual paths
of your code, there's more granular things
you can do with checking in code.
For instance, if you register a broadcast
receiver in your code, there's a version of
the API that specifies what permission the
caller must have before they're allowed to
invoke that component.
If you're receiving a binder call, say through
your AIDL file, you can use the enforce call-in
permissions or check calling permissions methods
to check whether the caller has the appropriate
permissions.
And this allows you to avoid the confused
deputy problem.
So what's a confused deputy problem?
So we have our Wi-Fi manager here which is
inside the system server which I call the
strict sheriff.
And say you want to make a Wi-Fi control app
that enables Wi-Fi peer-to-peer mode like
we were discussing before.
So if your app asks the strict sheriff here
whether he's allowed to do it, you would be
granted.
It you installed an attacker app that requested
no such permission and he asked the strict
sheriff, it would be denied.
But what happens if your app is exposing a
component that is part of the Wi-Fi control
and the attacker decides that he can ask your
app.
Well, your app might be asked by the attacker
app, it would ask the strict sheriff, he would
grant it because you asked for the permission
during installation and your app could return
some information back to the attacker app
without having the correct permission and
your app has become the confused deputy.
He's being deputized by the strict sheriff
and he's leaked information to the other app
without the correct permission.
>>Jon Larimer: So now I would like to talk
about protecting your app's data from people
with physical access to the device.
And I don't mean the users that installed
your app, they generally have every right
to access all the data that your app's storing
on the device on their behalf, but I'm talking
about people who maybe found or stole the
phone from someone.
The Android debuggable attribute and the Androidmanifest.XML
file turns on debugging for your app.
And you want to make sure that this isn't
enabled in release builds of your app.
And it's usually automatically disabled when
you create a replace APK, but if you've been
messing around with build process, it's possible
to release an APK with it enabled and we have
seen apps that were released the bug setting
enabled.
If it is enabled, someone with debug access
to the device, if ADB is enabled and USB-to-bugging
is enabled they can actually run code with
the same permissions as your app and read
of your app's data.
Here you can see how easy it is.
It takes a single shell command to run another
shell as user ID giving access to the private
secrets file that's full of secrets.
Something else that's worth mentioning is
the Android allow backup attribute which isn't
on this slide but it specifies that your app
allows private data to be backed up by the
Android backup system.
And in my opinion this is usually a pretty
good thing.
Users like being able to back up their data,
but you need to keep in mind that someone
with ADB access to the device can run ADB
backup and dump all of -- dump the backup
files, all the app's private data to get access
to this data.
Like I said, it's usually a good thing in
most cases, but if you have some extremely
sensitive information that you wouldn't want
someone who stole a phone to have access to,
then you might want not to allow backups.
Now let's talk about storing data, and in
particular, storing data in the files on the
file system.
So when you store personal data or data that's
protected by a permission, you need to make
sure that you aren't leaking this data to
other apps.
And the example I gave at the beginning of
this talk was storing the latest
GPS location in a world-readable file but
really if there's any information that you
retrieve from Android that requires a permissions
access or any data that the user enters into
your app, you don't want it to be world-readable
and you also need to watch out for when you're
using external storage.
In Android, the external storage or the SD
card, isn't protected by the same set of granular
app permissions that private files get and
it was designed to be used as shared storage,
where any app can access it.
And in Jelly Bean we added the ability to
protect extra storage with a permission but
any app can request this permission.
So this means that if your app is handling
any personal or private data, you really shouldn't
store it on external storage or the SD card
without asking the user first and making sure
that they're aware that any other app can
access this data.
Another important thing I'd like to say is
that you can't trust files that any other
app can write to.
It's usually a bad idea to create a world
writeable file anyways, but other apps can
still get access to write to files that your
app stores in external storage, right, external
storage permission allows this.
And I have a couple few really big don'ts
here.
If you're using any code libraries or external
libraries, don't place the code anywhere that
it can be written to by other apps.
Another one is don't write paths to code libraries
in world writeable files because then an app
can just load that file, change the path of
the file to a library that they control and
then your app would end up loading that binary
library into their own process space and it
could be possibly malicious and executing
in the context of your app with all of your
app's permissions using as your app's user
ID and this has actually happened before in
some very popular apps.
If you're going to be reading world writeable
data, you shouldn't do it with native code.
Dalvik offers protection against memory corruption
vulnerabilities that are really hard to prevent
in native code.
It takes a lot of effort.
And by memory corruption vulnerabilities I
mean the things like buffer overflows or integer
overflows that lead to arbitrary code execution.
Here's an example of some good and some bad
code for handling private data files.
And you can see here that it's pretty easy
to make sure that other apps can't read or
write to your files.
And it's actually less characters to type
mode private than mode world readable so it
actually takes a little bit more effort to
write the apps insecurely.
And the default value is actually zero so
you could just use zero instead of contacts
no private.
So you need to put a little bit of extra effort
into making your app insecure so that's one
of the examples of it's actually easier to
make a secure app, slightly, very slightly
easier.
So something else that you might consider
to protect your files from being accessed
is encryption but Kenny would like to say
a few words about that So as Jon mentioned,
permissions don't work on the SD card because
the file system used on the SD card for maximum
compatibility with consumer electronic devices
like your camera, where you put the SD card
in, doesn't support the concept of file owners.
So you might think to yourself, I know, I'll
just encrypt the file I put on the SD card,
then no bad guy will be able to read them.
Well, the problem is there's something called
like -- there's some attacks and one of them
is the chosen-ciphertext attack.
So what might happen is your encrypt your
loginok=0 in this example, but if the bad
guy knows that it's always going to be login
okay equals something or he can guess kind
of the pattern of the file, he can exhort
with the data he thinks it is and then exhort
with the data he wants it to be, and then
when you later decrypt that file, it will
become what he wants it to be.
That's not a good idea.
So a lot of this problem comes from trying
to compose your own cryptography primitives
without really understanding the consequences
and the pitfalls you might run into.
So it's a good idea just to use something
that's been peer-reviewed already, and one
such library is Keyczar.
Keyczar was written by the Google security
team, and it's made available under the Apache
2.0 license and it can handle encryption and
decryption, signing and verification of files
without much guesswork as to how to actually
use it.
For instance, on the slide there's a Keyczar
tool you run to create a key pair, the public
and private part.
Take that public part and put it in your raw
resources and later on in your application,
after you've packaged up that public key,
you can -- if you need to send data to your
server later, you can encrypt your private
data, you can store it away for a while, if
you want to, but later on you can send it
up to your server and on the server use Keyczar
to encrypt it.
And it's really only two lines of code.
And so it's a lot easier than instantiating
a lot of the Java cryptography objection and
every API should be that simple, in my opinion.
I'm working on it, but -- so just to show
how tricky crypto can be, in 1970s Ron Rivest,
Adi Shamir and Len Adleman took about 42 tries
to get RSA right.
Those are the R, S, and A in RSA.
And that means they got it wrong 41 times
beforehand.
And these guys are experts.
They've been researching cryptography a long
time.
So it just shows how easy it is to get things
wrong.
And more recently, NIST has opened up the
competition for the secure hash algorithm,
Version 3 or SHA-3.
64 people entered that, and immediately, crypt
analysts were attacking the algorithms.
Some were broken immediately, some were deemed
too slow, and some just not secure enough
in the competition.
Now, in the third round, there's five people
left, so that means 59 people got some things
wrong.
And I just don't want to see anyone in this
room end up in the same area.
So just use something like cryptography -- or
Keyczar for your cryptography.
And just to paraphrase a -- one of my favorite
games, it's dangerous to go alone.
Take this peer-verified cryptography library
with you.
Now I'd like to talk about protecting the
network trafficking in your app.
Most apps will connect to the Internet for
something.
They might be transmitting personal data,
and there's nothing particularly wrong about
this as long as you include that privacy policy
that Jon talked about.
But there's a problem if you're transmitting
it unencrypted.
Now, you can imagine a public Wi-Fi network.
If someone's on a public Wi-Fi network, anyone
in the room can basically sniff the traffic
on that public Wi-Fi network.
And even if you encrypt the public Wi-Fi network,
there might be a problem in the network between
your server and your client.
There could be an attacker in there that could
mount what is called a "man in the middle"
attack.
They can even inject data into your application
like they could intercept the connection and
appear as if you're connecting to the server
but they're injecting malicious data into
your application.
So you can't even really trust what's coming
into your application even if you know that
the local network's encrypted.
So what's the worst that can happen if someone
hijacks a network stream?
Well, I think the best that could happen is
that they see pictures of my neighbors' cats
instead of the images they're expecting to
see.
So I like my neighbors' cats, but you can
imagine something else happening like maybe
they're injecting malicious data, maybe they're
injecting JavaScript into your WebView.
It could be anything, really.
If you've ever been to a hacker conference
like DEF CON or Black Hat in Las Vegas and
tried to use a public Wi-Fi you might have
seen something -- it might be a little less
tame than this but you'll know what I mean.
But in the worst case, your app could be completely
compromised if it's exposing some JavaScript
interface in the WebView or whatever you're
downloading.
Luckily it's pretty easy to make -- to enable
encryption if you're using http in Android.
Just make sure you use https instead of http.
Just one little letter you put in there makes
a whole lot of difference.
Of course you need to make sure your server
is supporting https.
But that's really outside the scope of this
talk and there's plenty of things on the Web
you can go and search on how to enable https
or SSL on your server.
Something else to keep in mind is that you
really shouldn't download code into your program.
Android allows us -- you can download a DEX
file and actually load it into your applications
process space.
But it's a really bad idea security-wise.
So I really wouldn't recommend it.
And remember the cats from the last slide,
imagine if, instead of the DEX file you intended,
it's some attacker's DEX file that completely
comprises your application and they'd be able
to get access to all the data your app has
generated or the permissions it has granted
by the user.
If you know what you're doing, you can use
cryptographic signing to ensure that nothing
like this happens.
As we saw on the previous slide, it's hard
to get cryptographic signing right.
It's better to use Android's own updating
mechanism and to provide the freshest data
to your applications.
There's a good one in Google Play, by the
way.
By default, the https stack in Android will
validate SSL certificates against all the
CAs included in the Android platform.
This is fine and it provides an adequate level
of security by placing your trust in all the
trustworthiness of all the CAs, which, I don't
know if you guys have read the news, but there
was a few break-ins in CAs.
And when a bad guy breaks into a trusted CA
and generates a rogue certificate for a site,
if that rogue certificate is used, the user
won't be able to tell because it actually
validates correctly.
But breaking into a CA and generating rogue
certificates isn't something that a hobbyist
hacker or a script kiddie is able to do, these
guys are really serious.
And they're usually not after money, they're
after information.
So if your app is used by people in particularly
sensitive areas and you want to protect your
app a little bit more, you might want to consider
implementing certificate pinning.
So certificate pinning, if you know some CA
or intermediate certificate in a chain that
will never change, you can place that certificate
or a group of certificates in a pin set and
then that means that -- in the pin set and
trust only the group instead of everything
in the default list.
And what's even better is if you control the
software which runs on the client, which you
obviously do, and the server as well, you
can generate your own CA.
So then you can save a little bit of money
if you're strapped for cash.
But, of course, if you generate your own CA,
there's some protection you have to put in
place.
Like I mentioned before, a big corporation
might have an HSN for assigning capabilities.
Typically, they have something like they only
take it out at certain times of the year.
But you should really treat it the same as
your application signing key.
Make multiple copies, keep a backup and keep
a backup and keep a backup.
But if you want to find out more about how
to actually pin your certificates, you can
check the Android documentation for https
URL connection.
There's some example code in there.
So now I would like to give you some advice
for using WebView.
And by default, all JavaScript is disabled
in WebView, and this is good.
When you enable JavaScript, you open up your
application to attacks like cross-site scripting,
cross-site request forgery and people could
write heap spray exploits for WebKit bugs.
There's all sorts of bad things that can happen
if WebView in JavaScript is enabled.
We don't have time to get deep into those
specific attacks or how to block those attacks
today.
It's beyond the scope of this talk and we
just don't have time.
Keep in mind, you should keep JavaScript disabled
in your WebView unless there is some fundamental
reason your app requires it.
Because if an attacker can find a way to inject
arbitrary JavaScript into your application
either through man-in-the-middle attack as
Kenny was talking about, or even compromising
your web server, they could end up running
code in the context of your app.
This is especially dangerous if your WebView
exports a JavaScript interface.
And the add JavaScript interface method is
really dangerous.
What this call does is expose your app's functionality
through JavaScript.
For example, you could write a method at that
reads data from a file in your app's private
storage and post it back to your server.
And then you can make this method available
to JavaScript that's running in the WebView.
If an attacker has any way to control which
JavaScript is running in the WebView, and
your code -- say your code let's the JavaScript
read any file instead of a specific file,
like the file name is an argument to the method,
then you could have a major information leak
on your hands because -- so if you expose
any protected data or any phone capabilities
through JavaScript, like I said a web site
compromise or man-in-the-middle attack could
end up executing arbitrary code.
There are some legitimate uses for using add
JavaScript interface; that's why we put it
in there.
It is useful sometimes.
If you do use it, make sure you are grabbing
the JavaScript over https.
Make sure it is an encrypted and authenticated
connection.
Don't expose anything that's protected by
a permission.
Make sure that the -- any information you
do expose is extremely limited.
So for example, don't provide a generic interface
for reading and writing files to JavaScript
and don't expose direct access to content
providers, and definitely don't expose access
to, like, reflection.
So you really want to keep the potential attack
surface as small as possible.
Something else that we like to talk about
is minimizing the permissions that your app
requests.
And you already know that requesting too many
unnecessary permissions can get you a lot
of bad reviews from users.
People complain on the forums.
That's not the only problem with requesting
too many permissions in your apps.
Recently a group of university researchers
found that one third of the app that is they
tested requested more permissions than they
needed.
This means that, based on the code that was
in the apps, they requested permissions that
they didn't have any code that used.
So there's extra permissions floating around
that weren't really necessary.
And this is a problem because if there's a
security vulnerability in the app, if an app
can run arbitrary code in the context of the
app, using one of the vulnerabilities that
we already talked about, they can take advantage
of any of the permissions that you request.
So your app might not be using them, but a
malicious app could.
So I'd like to show you a few examples of
ways that your app can perform common tasks
without requesting permissions.
And these are things that most people think
actually require permission and I've seen
some of this very similar code in apps and
they request a permission that they don't
need.
So when I say that you can do these things
without requesting permission, I don't mean
that you can, like, do these things like access
data secretly behind the user's back without
permission.
The user is fully aware of what's going on.
They are prompted to select the piece of information
to share with your app.
So in the first example, you'll see how you
don't need to request a permission yourself
if you call an activity that already has the
permission that your app needs.
And in the second example, you will see how
content providers can grant temporary permissions
for your app to access some data.
So here's one example.
If you want to let the user take a picture
with a camera and then read that image data
in your app, you don't need the camera permission
for your app.
You can just launch the camera system activity
to let the user take a picture and then return
control to your own app.
So to make this happen, you fire off an action
image capture intent and specify whatever
output file name that you want.
You can use start activity for result to make
sure that your app gets called back with the
data whenever the activity is complete.
So in this case, after the user takes the
picture, your on activity result callback
in your class gets the file path and you can
read the file.
So from the user's perspective and from a
security and privacy perspective, this is
a lot safer than granting camera to the app
and writing a bunch of code to interface with
the camera API.
The user gets to pick the photo to that is
sent to the app.
Can't open the camera -- can't read camera
data without actually opening the camera and
the user seeing it there.
There's no reason to request the camera permission
unless you are actually writing a camera app
yourself.
Another example is letting the user send an
SMS message.
Instead of requesting the send SMS permission
and going through all of the effort of talking
to the telephony manager to send an SMS message,
you can create an intent and start an activity
to launch as the system SMS app with the message
and app that you choose.
This way the user gets to see the destination
phone number and message.
They will have an option of either sending
it or declining to send it if they aren't
comfortable with it.
Or they can change the message.
Obviously, this won't work for an app that
-- for every app that has SMS features.
But if SMS is just a minor part of your app,
for example if you want to let the user share
a link to your app to one of their contacts
through SMS, letting them send the message
this way makes a lot of sense.
You don't have to worry about freaking the
user out by requiring send SMS permission
if that's the only feature you will be using
it for.
Something else that's pretty neat is that
content providers can grant temporary permissions
to apps.
An app can use the action pic or ActionGetContent
to have the system launch an activity that
let's the user pick the information they want
to share with your apps.
Here's an example.
Let's say you want to get some contact information
from the user.
So instead of requiring the read contacts
permission and spending a bunch of time writing
a new widget to let users scroll through the
contacts and pick the ones they want.
You can use ActionGetContent with the mine
type of phone.content item type, and the Android
system will pop up a contact chooser that
let's the user pick which contact they want.
When the user makes their choice, the on activity
result callback for your class is called.
Then you can use a content resolver to read
the data that you want.
This works because the context content provider
grants a temporary URI-based permission, which
we really didn't get into, to your app for
this one piece of information.
Your app can read this contact but it can't
read any others and they don't have access
to read the full list and the user picks the
contact themself.
So I think users will feel much better about
this privacy and security-wise than just granting
blanket access to your app to read the entire
contact list.
Another thing I want to talk about minimizing
permissions is identifying app installations.
And this is a pretty common problem.
There are a lot of reasons why you'd want
to identify unique installations, whether
it be for licensing or tracking game scores
or advertising or even just getting an accurate
count of the active users I don't have you
are app.
People seem to be inclined to use get device
ID for this or the sim serial number or some
hardware-based ID.
The hardware IDs aren't great values for tracking
installs.
The device ID isn't really reliable on -- and
some devices, and on some customer OMs it's
just set to a fixed value.
There was a very popular phone that's shipped
that's still widely used today that had a
fixed device ID on every single phone.
There was also the privacy implication that
the user can't change this value without buying
a new phone.
If someone decides to do a factor reset on
their device and sell the phone to someone
else, and then the buyer also purchases your
app, they can see some weird stuff if your
app is associating that phone with another
user.
You don't want the new owner of the phone
to see all of the old user's personal data
if you are storing it keyed on the device
ID.
So you could use the Android ID to track installs.
It doesn't require permission and it does
get changed on a device swipe.
But this really still isn't ideal.
My favorite method is -- security and privacy-wise,
is just generate an UUID, universal unique
identifier, when the app starts up for the
first time and then store it in the shared
preferences file.
Then you can use the Android backup system
so the shared preference file for your app
is synced up to the Cloud.
That way the user can actually wipe the ID
if they want.
They can go to the system settings and clear
the apps data.
If they feel like they need to do a factory
reset of the phone, they can do a backup,
factory reset their phone, resync the device
back to the Cloud and your ID will still be
there and will still see the same data from
the app.
This is really the best of both worlds.
The value is persistent across swipes if the
user wants it to be, or they can erase the
value without doing a full factory reset.
So it ends up working a lot like web browser
cookie.
So now let's talk a bit about device administrator
access.
The Android device administration API let's
anyone develop and publish apps that can control
the administrative security features of the
device.
Things like requiring a lock screen with a
complex password or requiring encryption,
disabling the camera or doing something fun
like wiping the device.
So if your app does request device administrator
privileges, it works a little differently
than the normal permission system.
Users can actually revoke device administration
privileges.
And the privileges are also granted on a more
granular basis.
An app can ask for the ability to enforce
the password length or password complexity
but still not be able to wipe the device.
And some issues we have seen in the past are
that people who install apps that require
device administration access, they can't uninstall
these apps unless device administration is
disabled.
Android versions up to Gingerbread, there
wasn't really a clear error here.
It would say uninstall failed.
The user would have no idea why they can't
uninstall these apps and they think it's malware.
But in Ice Cream Sandwich and up, the user
has the option of going directly to the settings
to disable the app.
So if you're using device administrator access
in a normal app and not like an actual enterprise
mobile device management solution, for example
if you developing a lock screen or a replacement
for the default launcher, make sure that your
users are aware of the power that they are
giving your app.
Make sure that they know that they have a
disabled device administrator privileges to
uninstall your app.
And I have been saying the whole time that
you need to be really careful with security
but you should be really careful if your app
has access to any of the more dangerous device
administrator privileges because accidentally
leaking someone's private notes or their email
address is one thing.
But letting some other app wipe the device
without permission is a whole other problem
and you really don't want to have to deal
with that.
So I don't know if you guys have seen it,
but we reasonably started including a tool
call Android Lint with the Android SDK.
It's been there since around version 16 of
the development kit tools.
And what it does is it scans your Android
project source code, the Java and the XML
files, for potential bugs.
Besides normal bugs like bugs that can crash
your program or performance issues, Lint actually
checks for several potential security issues
that we talked about today, too.
And Lint is integrated with Eclipse, so if
it finds an issue, it will generate a warning
and point the problem out to you with the
yellow squiggly line that you probably can't
see on the projector under mode world writable.
When you do see this warning, you can hover
the mouse over it and click a menu option
to get more detailed information.
Here you can see we are urging you to carefully
review the code that's creating a world writable
file.
It tells you not to write any private data
to the file.
It let's you know if the file is modified
by malicious code, it can compromise your
entire application.
Besides looking for world readable and world
writable files, Lint also checks for exported
application components that can be accessed
without permission.
It's not always a vulnerability to export
a service or broadcast receiver or a content
provider without permission.
Sometimes that's exactly what you're intending
to do, but Lint is there to make sure that
you know that you are doing it.
So when you see these Lint security warnings,
whatever you do, don't ignore them.
You can suppress the warnings with an annotation,
it's just a menu option and adds the code
automatically, but you should really only
do that once you understand the security issue
that is causing the warning and fully aware
of the implications that -- of what you are
doing.
You could be making a huge mistake by ignoring
a security warning from Lint.
And we're also adding new security checks.
So make sure you are always using the latest
build of the SDK tools.
The SDK tools are released independently of
the Android operating system, so it's updated
a lot more frequently.
It's also developed mostly in open source.
So you can check out the source for Lint.
If you have ideas for more checks, you can
feel free to add them.
We will put them in the source code.
So definitely check that out if you haven't
seen it.
And we do have a lot of documentation on the
Android developer site and Android open source
project site.
There's some other good references out there,
too.
The Android security overview site describes
the security features in Android and how they
are implemented.
You should definitely check that out to get
a deeper understanding of Android's security
architecture and some of the underlying features
of the operating system that provide the basis
for the Android permission model and the various
security features the operating system provides.
The designing for security page tells you
how to write apps with security in mind.
This is probably the most important document
that you need to read to be able to design
and develop your app securely.
And on that page you will find a lot of the
same information that we talked about today.
How to avoid world readable and world writable
files.
How to protect your application components,
and encrypted network communications.
So definitely take a look at that if you haven't
seen it.
It's a relatively new document.
We just put it up a few months ago or late
last year.
I'm not sure how many people have seen it.
Then there's the documentation on the security
and permissions in Android.
If you do decide to export some of your application
components and require permission, definitely
read the permissions documentation very thoroughly.
It covers all aspect of the permission system
and there's a lot of good stuff that you need
to know.
And something else you might want to check
out is a book buy Jeff Six called Application
Security For The Android Platform.
It's short, a little over 100 pages, maybe
115 pages.
It's still very thorough.
We would like to think that the short lent
of this book is a testament to how easy it
is to write secure apps in Android.
>>Kenny Root: Thanks everyone.
If you have any questions about the Android
platform security features or general discussion,
there is a group called Android Security Discuss
on Google Groups.
If you want to report a security vulnerability
in the Android platform or any Google apps,
you can send email to security@android.com.
And we will probably be doing a Google hangout
-- Google+ hangout with the Android developer
office hours in August sometime.
So if you can't think of your question right
now, we will be hanging out with Reto and
the other guys on the Google+ hangout.
We only have about three minutes left.
We might be able to take a few questions.
But if you line up at the microphones in the
aisle, we will answer your questions.
[ Applause ]
>>> Can you tell us what exactly the device
encryption setting does and also how does
rooting affect security?
>>Kenny Root: So device encryption, you mean
the disk encryption?
Whole device encryption?
>>> Yes, in the settings.
>>Kenny Root: What it does, it basically turns
on -- on a low level, it use the Linux kernel
de-encrypt to encrypt the entire slash data
partition.
It basically encrypts it in place.
What was the other part -- how does rooting
--
>>> Rooting.
>>Kenny Root: How does rooting affect security?
>>> My concern is if somebody is rooting the
phone, does an app have access to your data
even if you have that encryption option turned
on?
>>Kenny Root: It depends on what it does exactly.
Basically when your device is running, it
has to access the data.
So if you -- if there's an application that
runs, it's going to be able to access the
data because it is unencrypted to the operating
system.
If it was totally encrypted for everything,
the device would be a brick basically.
If you have root permissions, you can read
some other applications.
>>> So you guys have this ability to request
a different context in the SDK.
Can you explain how that works with your security
model and whether or not another application
can request your resource bundle.
>>Kenny Root: Depends on if you have what's
called forward locking.
So basically you can request resources for
other applications.
This is what allows third-party launchers
to work.
So if you wanted to make a launcher, we load
up an icon or other resources, you have to
have that available for other third-party
launchers to be able to use.
That's why it's there.
You can also do things like create add-on
processes where you just install an application,
doesn't really have any code, but it can have
resources that you can load.
So you can enable the forward locking but
I think they took it out of the developer
console for Market.
>>> Just to be clear, does that mean other
applications can access my resources?
>>Kenny Root: Depends on where the resources
are.
But, yeah.
>>> Is there more guidance?
The documentation online leaves something
to be desired.
>>Kenny Root: Yeah, I don't know exactly where
it would be.
But I'll look it up and get back to you.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>> Are you guys familiar with sequel cipher
for Android and if so, what are your impressions?
>>Kenny Root: I'm not familiar with it.
>>Jon Larimer: I'm not familiar.
>>> It is a drop-in replacement for SQLite,
identical API, so you just use different imports
for SQLite database.
It provides full encryption of the database.
>>Kenny Root: I haven't heard of it.
>>Jon Larimer: I don't know it.
>>> It's good.
>>Jon Larimer: Somebody says it's good.
>>> It adds a bit to the package size but
the cost of having it self-secure.
>>Kenny Root: So adds to package size at the
cost of users being mad it takes up too much
room.
>>> Posting on the Motorola forum, something
about log --
>>Kenny Root: I think we have time for one
more question.
We have 20 seconds.
>>> It's my understanding that factory data
reset doesn't actually delete user's data
or do any sort of encryption or anything like
that.
I've heard reports of people doing factory
data reset with the impression that everything
would be completely hidden and then someone
buying their phone that knew what they were
doing.
>>Kenny Root: On some phones if you don't
have an SD card or if you have an SD card,
it won't wipe the SD card, a lot of people
take it out when they sell the phone.
On phones that have USB storage, no removable
SD card, there's an option that says delete
everything, including photos.
>>> Even if you -- even the data that is supposedly
deleting, it's actually just marking.
>>Kenny Root: If you are really paranoid,
you can always enable hold this encryption.
Basically that throws away the keys.
>>> I have my phone encryption.
My main question is really -- since it is
not really getting rid of that data, is there
any steps that we're supposed to be taking
to make sure that if someone finds themself
in that situation, the data in our apps is
not accessible.
>>Kenny Root: If you enable hold this encryption
when you do factory reset, it is getting rid
of the data.
>>Jon Larimer: We are out of time for questions.
But we will hang out up here on stage and
you guys can come up and talk to us.
[ Applause ]